you
all right this is the guy that I
apparently missed out on as I was doing
it guess the number so my apologies for
that we're gonna get this game in though
you had actually guessed a number before
somebody else but my eyes were not wide
open were they and hopefully my opponent
has the stream muted okay so clearly my
opponent wants to play here so I think
I'd do this
b5 and after d4 I say aha
I grab some space with E for and because
of that particular configuration because
of how its structured c4 would be the
way for white to go but if white is
playing that white has lost a move so
this is the direction that white should
be going in getting this advancing but
White's not going for that I might even
want to play here but maybe that is
unnecessary I could secure this point
well enough with just the night hand
bite buying well let's just develop by
not having a pond here I still have
possibilities for my LightSquared Bishop
now my first thought is to really chase
this night away with H 5 H 4 so let's
actually do it position is closed so
maybe I could afford this sort of idea
where I kick the night away Knights
Knights 10 - Knights that find
themselves on b3 b6 g 3 and g 6 tend to
be inconvenienced by the H pawns get out
of there and now he's got to run home I
could also play here and then really
look to invade on the light squares f3
in particular
maybe I go one step further let me do
that I would really really really like
to have the LightScribe bishops come off
so let me do this plate Queen here and
Bishop here that's my idea also this
move is directed at stopping this
advance my opponent plays f3 to strike
at my center where are they gonna castle
that's that's actually an interesting
question I don't know if I have a great
answer for it let's just go here what
okay let's go here is there a bishop
check is that useful probably not I'm
assuming that that move is played so
bishop here is available um
bishop here and I could do this kept in
the night I really want to give up my
bishop for the night though this guy
turned into a tough tough guy right
there pawn takes pawn takes Bishop here
I always have 96 so let me hmm hang on
Bishop here Bishop takes Knight takes
pawn takes pawn takes Knight takes pawn
Queen takes pawn my coin will be all
over overloaded actually Bishop here
Bishop takes Knight takes my queen has
to babysit the knight and the pond
however
I don't know let's go here I think I'm
gonna drop back with my Bishop Bishop
here inconvenience is this night he
wouldn't have asked where we'd pin here
and then maybe do this sort of thing
a bishop could be kicked away okay I
think I just want to drop back I'm
tactically vulnerable on b4 to Knight
takes here if I take the bishop the
knight recapture so I did this to
inconvenience okay I do have this Knight
move losing my queen again and I'd be a
bad one
I'm not trapping my queen I would be
pinning my Queen there okay so if my
opponent does have the intention of
giving up the bishop for night he is
going to have a field day he is going to
be a monster on these light squares I
should jump right in right now I have
this square covered so as soon as he
plays here he's dead I cannot deal with
the knight on c5 okay okay this is what
I wouldn't have happened so let me
exchange there the inside castle I don't
know not queenside castle now let's go
here though maybe maybe I should have
considered b6
Oh too late for that all right let's
take him out and play here otherwise
this Bishop is too tough now let's do
this let's open the position up I'm one
move away from being fully developed
capture capture I'm hitting the Queen
the knight jumping in here is too good
too good he goes from being called a
knight to a beast he transforms to a
beast if he's getting to f3 if he's
getting to this square it's already over
there's no way right too many good
prospects see to f3 maybe by force I
could get my knight in here d3 can't
really get to b4 and to that
where what is what is he going to do one
day I would like to get my queen on that
square for me that's always a nice idea
he's a significant problem for white the
King castling on this side whoa whoa
whoa whoa this queen is close to trapped
pawn push you could only go here
who cares about material actually this
isn't even losing material but I just
want to get at my opponents King they're
castling right into the line of fire and
now I'm just going to capture and I will
be castling this knight still actually
he doesn't he doesn't even have any
legal move so what does that mean that
means that he's playing without the
night or the rook here we're also going
to be castle on opposite wings is my
king going to be attacked is there way
to open up the position with this Jeep
on marching down not singing it I could
capture it the night or the pond but I'm
gonna take with the no no no no no I'm
gonna take I'll take with the night this
is an open position and I want to be
very forceful and this is the most
forceful move the most direct move gives
my opponent a lot of directions so let
me get castle this I might be losing a
pound look maybe not let's get him
involved Knight here I could have also
done and you know it's very strong Queen
takes here loses the whole farm actually
it's just over now because I'm on the
bishop maybe best is Bishop takes Knight
giving up two pieces for the Queen
probably the best option Bishop takes
Knight Knight takes Queen although you
know what maybe I can still just take
with the pond that might be strong with
Queen takes Knight here to follow
yeah this is this is a difficult
position here a lot of lot of trouble
was stirred up early on with that I
really just want to take here yeah I
think this is vast taking either pond
allows me to win the Queen here directly
with the fork here because of a
discovered attack and at the very least
I still get the exchange and still an
attack against the king so I guess
what's possible and this is something
that I was calculating where I'm up in
exchange in this variation I know more
than the exchange my bad I'm up two
rooks here but I could have swung over
here and got that guy let's just go here
two squares away diagonally from the
knight means it takes him four moves or
three moves one two three moves before
it's even a tackle that particular piece
all right good game age Huck let's go
back let's flip and let's see what
either one of us can do to improve I
think already I see the intention to
support d4 but because of how I
responded it makes life difficult for
you it's a sensible and good I'm
occupying the center and because of this
structural change where I gain some
space again like I was saying during the
game if huge to play c4 and eventually
you did that costs time and this cost me
some time as well I play d5 okay that's
a good move in itself I I could occupy
the center with a pawn I have some
control of the center but I spent some
more time by playing e4 so now I'm
taking away some good squares for your
pieces it becomes difficult for the
knight of course to pivot about its most
natural left three squares out the
window so that's the little trade-off
you you're gonna be wasting some time
and it's offset by I I've established a
pony while you wasted time
I put that time to good use because I
have a space advantage I have that pond
now and before and life becomes very
difficult and it's really when you have
this type of a central structure where
you will really want to pay much more
attention to the strategic idea of
exchanging good back good bishops and
bad bishops we could identify those
already he's the bad bishop and he's the
bad bishop and it's already tough my one
concern was maybe should you be striking
at this pond right away with f3 but I
think it's really already going all the
way back maybe it's something you
already recognizes not the greatest
thing and it's just something you go
with because it's comfortable to you and
that's I I could completely understand
that as well
playing practically just something that
you've done over and over but I think of
objectively speaking it's it's not a
good approach to be going with the c3
III and then d4 how about this I mean
just as a slight improvement play III
and then d4 and then you're retaining
some options with your C pawn maybe
maybe you still go maybe you still go to
c3 maybe you go to sea for you you make
black show their hand before you commit
your C pawn so that's just a slight
tweaking of the position of the pawn
moves and this is this is quite
difficult now I think it's just way
beyond repair I have a space advantage
and an advantage with what else I have
an advantage with development as well
and these are too many
too many advantages behind in
development he's stuck it's quite
difficult to get him working so just
opening the position up and those are
just some quick tips alrighty good game
age Huck